I'm losing track of the days and yet
another incredible day female genital
mutilation it's not often you hear that
phrase Melinda Gates I managed to corner
her and she was leaving the building at
a very quick chat and she's also
promised to follow up through the eight
scholarships why don't you give us our
cup your pardon Monsieur Gabrielle if
she didn't enjoy our very own David
Cameron from the UK the leader of the
Conservative Party I was pleased to hear
that he knew about it something that
actually is affecting you know potential
families people in the UK
as Africa else is subject to take
extremely seriously
and a really important meeting for me
today was very briefly to be introduced
to the president of Senegal I think this
regard as you said make very effusive
sorry this problem but where she could
muster loop on the other country to
bring them to a browser and sanitary
system had a really great meetings
morning with Kathy Calvin from the UN
foundation there's a very specific
foundation that looks at women and child
health today we really made this a high
priority and helped all those 140
million women who've already been
victims and changed the culture the
girls in the future we had a great
meeting with the Minister of Finance
from Rwanda and it was very heartening
to hear his words about women's
empowerment and the role of women in his
society I could have a special unit into
our police force
that's protects women again is Vienna
just violence so there are many
initiatives we've run about to
supporting women we also spelled with
William Hague yeah I think this is this
is the way to do it by the way what
you'll do it because you now can through
multimedia raised all kinds issue the
parliaments having discussed adequate
the president of the International
Labour Organization no let me first
congratulate you you know it's not easy
to get here and to be understood in
terms of what you're trying to do I
think that every course is legitimate in
this unit you may remember i said this
issue has to move out of the margins and
what I feel today is that all these
different pieces are coming together in
a way that's really going to allow me to
follow up and hopefully make sustainable
change